so I guess everybody knew before they
were here today that this is a very long
story and we're now to the beginning of
the next part of the long story I'm
gonna try hard to stay on time
there's 21 years more to go after after
the story that you just heard which took
a long time so I'm gonna pick up the
story in 1994 and in 1994 was when we
received for the first time project
funding to actually build something
which is the LIGO detector with all the
responsibility of getting tens of
millions of dollars a year for 20 years
and defending it during a period where
we saw nothing during that whole time so
the first thing that people should
realize is that the National Science
Foundation not only took the risk that
ray mentioned in taking on this project
doing the R&D and so forth
but after it was taken on they had to
defend a project with all the risks that
it had for 20 years with essentially no
results we basically set various limits
because we didn't see anything but for
no results and so we're probably
indebted more to the NSF and one can
imagine and taking on such a project we
organized it by a collaboration between
Caltech and MIT and that shouldn't be
lost in the story because we now have a
thousand scientists around the world but
we have at the center of all this what
we call the light LIGO laboratory and
the LIGO laboratory is the group that
actually has built and made the detector
work the responsibility for the detector
is Caltech and MIT and we've organized
that as a project we have about a
hundred and fifty technicians scientists
and so forth the scientists in this
group do their science in what we call
the LIGO science collaboration but the
instrument has been built by us the
president director is Dave Wright see
whose picture is up there and the deputy
director is Albert Lazzarini and they're
running
today while we're doing all this
fantastic science and earlier after I
was director was Jay marks who led it
during the crucial period when we took
on advanced LIGO next in about 1997 we
realized that the Caltech and MIT
collaboration didn't bring all the
elements we were going to need to
succeed at this project and certainly
not all the scientific ones so we
created what people have heard about
today and that is the LIGO scientific
collaboration bringing in talents
varying from experts and lasers to
experts on and now artificial
intelligence in order to take the whole
breadth of talents they can be brought
to this incredibly difficult problem and
pull it together that's grown from what
started as tens of people in the
collaboration run by Ray who I appointed
at that point at the time to run the
collaboration to a collaboration now
that's very democratic with elected
officers and is read run presently by
david shoemaker by gabriela gonzalez
during the period where we made the
first detection before that by Dave
Wright see who now is running the
laboratory and Peter sawsan who you
heard about was after after ray this is
a magnificent success of international
collaboration of the ability to bring in
the talents that we need whether its
technical whether its data analysis
whether it's theoretical together
working together side by side we have 18
countries involved in LIGO more than a
hundred institutions and about 1,200
collaborators of which a thousand were
with us long enough that they were
credited with authorship on our
discovery paper the interferometers
themselves are organized with some
critical people that have run it from
the beginning we've had somebody who's
at these sites that are distant and not
close to a city
and run by two people originally fred
rob and mark coles who later went to the
National Science Foundation and
presently by Mike Landry who newly took
over Hanford the Hanford Observatory and
Joe Giambi in Livingston so if you visit
either of those laboratories that's who
you see and their remote one in distant
Louisiana far from any city and the
other on a do a reservation in Eastern
Washington just to see just to show you
what things look like in the real
hardware this is a picture of LIGO if
you walked into the big hall where this
is the vertex that Ray showed where the
light then goes out in two directions
this big thing here are called gate
valves they allow us to preserve the
fantastic vacuum that Ray talked about
that we need to while we work and evolve
the instrument these instruments that
you look at here aren't quite as simple
as what ray showed and part of that is
building in enough flexibility all these
ports and all the ways of getting in so
that from the beginning we understood
that if we're ever gonna detect
gravitational waves what we built at the
beginning wasn't going to probably make
it so we had to be able to evolve the
instrument and in ways that we weren't
sure how to do it so we as much as
possible we asked the NSF for more
funding at the beginning and made as
flexible an instrument as we possibly
could we build it by the end of maybe
1999 we had it built and then we started
making it work and this picture kind of
illustrates how we approach the next 15
years
we basically this is the same curve that
was shown by Ray where it's limited on
the left side by the shaking of the
earth on this side by the amount of
light and in between by the noise on
these test masses that we talked about
and better sensitivity is the bottom of
the plot it's the same scale that Ray
showed and this is the frequency band
that's available to us to look for
gravitational waves it's a
the audio ban where the earth is the
quietest each each curve here is
basically subsequently a different time
so our strategy basically was to turn
this on it was that whatever sensitivity
it was this isn't very sensitive look
our wounds look at what we did wrong
what was limiting it take time off run
it again and it evolved to a better
curve a better curve a better curve this
is about the first five years of the
detector we kept doing this for ten
years at each at each time we would
search for gravitational waves each time
we wouldn't find gravitational waves
each time we would have a better limit
because this was better on how well we
knew they didn't appear and so we wrote
a series of papers but they basically
were null papers during that period
along the way we got to the point where
we were as good as we had proposed
except maybe a little bit at the low
frequencies and this that's this curve
here so this is the initial detector
that we were funded for by the National
Science Foundation on the same kind of
graph as good as we could we knew very
early as Ray had indicated that we
wanted to do this in two stages that we
can incrementally improve things but
only so far without making some major
changes so we had done the detailed Rd
necessary to develop the techniques and
the apparatus itself the detailed
designs that would go into a second
generation detector and that was what we
called advanced LIGO interestingly we
called it like o2 but the NSF in their
wisdom decided that we were sneaky ly
talking about LIGO one two three four so
they asked us to change the name and it
became advanced LIGO with advanced LIGO
we then build it between nineteen twenty
ten and twenty thirteen or so and
started turning it on we could we
basically had learned a lot so we turned
it on a lot
faster than we had the initial I go
getting nearer designed sensitivity by
2015 it started to work well enough so
that it was better than what we had
built for initial LIGO and that is shown
here the key people by the way for
advanced LIGO some of the key people I
show over here Dennis Coyne who was
shown earlier has stayed with us as our
chief engineer and was the engineer
responsible for the fantastic
engineering that goes into advanced LIGO
David shoemaker who's running the
collaboration now was basically the the
main scientist responsible for advanced
LIGO and Peter official for the
incredible optics that we use and the
way the interferometer works itself and
two people one in each laboratory who
have been the most responsible for the
making this thing actually work in the
field and so we started to make it work
and the two detectors are in the two
different colors here and what they
indicate is that despite the fact that
they're physically in very different
locations so basically in design and as
long as we do the same thing at the same
time they were essentially identically
to each other at this point
this had improved about a factor of
three beyond where we were in in initial
LIGO our goal was to improve things a
factor of 10 this is improving the
sensitivity a factor of 3 and what to
realize is that the sensitivity tells
you how far out you look in the universe
so if we increase the sensitivity a
factor of 3 we actually improve how much
of the universe we're looking at by the
cube of that because that's the volume
that's scanned so an improvement of a
factor of 3 basically gave us the
ability to do what we had done in
initial LIGO or more in one year what we
could have done in 27 years with initial
I go
so we decided not to go all the way to
here but have a similar strategy to what
we had an initial LIGO and use this as
the first search because we had improved
the concept for how we treat low
frequencies which was described by Ray
the improvement as say 40 Hertz was
actually a factor of a hundred shown
here a factor of a hundred is cubed in
terms of the sensitivity we get so we
were really a million times better than
we were an initial I go and that answers
a question that's often asked to us how
could we turn this thing on and after a
few days which is what happened make a
discovery when we had run it for ten
years before that are almost ten years
and it's really this factor of a million
so we turned on advanced LIGO and made
that improvement again this is just a
picture to emphasize that the big
improvement that made this detection may
be the take-home message if you want to
tell anybody why and how we made the
detection was the improvement in this
nice quadruple and fancy suspension
system developed at Glasgow and the
suspected the isolation from the earth
by seismic isolation from the earth by a
set of essentially shock absorbers and
these active seismic feedback systems
that Ray mentioned that by the way have
two reason their how so hard it has to
be done directionally differently than
the earphones and the airplane we have
to know where the earth is shakiness
what direction and correct for it and
that makes the system quite a bit more
difficult we turned on and a few days
later this is what we found so this was
September 14 2015 21 years after we
received project funding in 1994 not
what my fantasies were most of us for
what we first see I would have expected
if I thought about what we would see
that we start to see hints of
gravitational waves where our detector
wasn't quite sensitive enough yet to
make it definitively and then we keep
working in the future and making it more
sensitive
we were lucky instead we of course made
big improvements but we immediately saw
a signal that stood out and looked very
much like you draw to show somebody what
we were doing this is two different
traces one of them at the laboratory in
eastern Washington Hanford Laboratory
and one in Louisiana and they should
look essentially alike
you'll notice the left-hand side is
strain the word that ray used and the
scale is the scale he also showed 10 to
the minus 21 so the scale that we were
detecting and got to the sensitivity to
detect and also the scale that had more
or less been predicted by the range of
sources that we talked about was ten to
the minus twenty-one and that turned out
to be after all these years right and
these are the two traces if I take the
two traces and plot them on top of each
other and slide one slightly from the
other one by seven 6.9 milliseconds then
they sat essentially right on top of
each other as you can see here and the
difference between the time between the
two I'll point out in a minute gives us
information that's crucial especially
for the future so those are the two
detection by the way we made a decision
in 1994 finally we had to make the
decision in 1994 how to orient these two
detectors relative to each other they
can't be exactly the same because the
earth curves by 16 degrees between
Livingston Louisiana and Hanford
Washington but there was a rather large
debate whether we take the two l-shaped
detectors and make them parallel to each
other or rotate them by 45 degrees the
reason you would rotate them by 45
degrees is it gives you the ability to
extract more physics
that is there's a polarization in these
electromagnetic in these gravitational
waves just like for electromagnetic
waves so the argument to rotate them is
exactly that the argument to put them in
parallel is what I showed you here that
we could put one on top of the other
we did it one on top of the other in
conservatism and of course it's what
made one event so convincing that we
could put one on top of the other but we
couldn't tell the polarization
information that has come and I'll talk
in a minute by adding a third detector
that is oriented separately from us
that's the Virgo detector and that start
has started to give us information on
the polarization we detected this event
in September of 2015
did we immediately know it was
gravitational waves not really most of
us are some of us at least had deep
worries how we might be mistaken how we
might be fooling ourselves or how we
might be being fooled those two
questions basically in translation were
that we turned on a new apparatus and in
turning on a new effort attaced maybe it
could generate some sort of shaky
signals but they weren't real and in
order to test that you have to run it
for some period of time we calculated
how long that had to be and it was
basically a month in a month's time we
could look at all the bins of time in
the to correlate them together and see
what the probability is that you could
get any sort of signal like this in the
detector and that's calculated to be a
magic number in physics when you believe
something which we call five Sigma or
the probabilities less than one in some
hundreds of thousands of years so
basically that was the first thing the
second problem was maybe somehow we were
being fooled by some mischievous people
our person who has superposed this on
the data and we just looked at the data
and it really wasn't there that again
had
be studied in great detail by his
following the idea was the following the
data comes together at Caltech and from
that time on goes around the world in
fact this first event was seen first in
Germany it was the middle of the night
in the States and the data comes
together once it's together you could
imagine somebody superposing
an event on top of the data to resolve
that we have to take it back to the
laboratories where we had traced the
signals and what they recorded along the
way and that required another study
which took about a month so by a middle
of October I think we had really
confidence that we had made this
discovery we spent maybe another month
seeing how well it fits general
relativity I spent in another month
writing it up in great detail writing it
up in a way that we thought could be
read by the world and not just by
experts in the field arguing about
whether it should be called an
observation or a discovery and things
like that with a thousand people
weighing in and you can imagine can
somehow making that converge was a
problem we finally were ready to submit
this to Physical Review Letters our
choice of where to publish this by early
December of 2015 we were about a week
late because we were arguing too long on
which adjectives to use in the paper and
at that point Physical Review Letters
who had agreed that they would allow us
to make the article longer than the
standard article and that they would
review it especially both very secretly
and quickly informed us that we were now
too close to Christmas and they couldn't
do it
so we held the article until January and
interestingly our second event which I
show now came on December 26th so when
we announced this event on February of
20 2016 we knew but we didn't yet bring
that to the public that we also had a
second event so as convincing as the
first of that was
we all have a second event it looks very
different you can see this has many many
oscillations it's smaller but we detect
it as well because there's so many
oscillations that's a reflection of the
fact that they are lighter the two black
holes that are colliding it's also black
hole collisions this graph here just
illustrates it's the so-called chirp
graph this is basically time going this
way frequency going this way it gets
louder as the frequency goes up and just
get this so-called chirp that we
describe as a signal the second one
which is weaker but in there longer so
we are able to pull out the signal is
down here but if we look at basically
the low frequencies that weren't
available to us until we made the big
improvement in the suspension and the
isolation system both of these signals
were enabled by making those
improvements at low frequencies of
course we've kept running we finished
that first data run with these two
events in January of 2016 and at that
point we changed things fixed things in
the same spirit that I presented our
activities through the period of initial
like oh and we started a second day to
run which may be for most of us we
expect it couldn't possibly be as
exciting as what we saw in the first day
to run that turned out to be wrong as
I'll show you in the second data run I
show here that we haven't analyzed all
the data yet we haven't made all our
reports yet but this is where we are
today we basically have reported five
observations of probably black holes one
of them we don't call a black hole just
because it's further away and doesn't
give us quite the five Sigma's
significance as a single event but
otherwise it appears to be like the
others so we have a set of events which
start to let us look at distributions of
the alignments of spin
the masses of them and the difference in
how long they are is the difference in
how much their masses are and so forth
so the fifth one here actually has a
different significance that's this one
here the dates are the 17th the 8th
month the 14th day in 2017 so just this
last August so this last August we
detect an event that at the same time
was detected for the first time also in
the Virgo detector in Italy the Virgo
detector is very much like LIGO I don't
have time to show some interesting
differences in how they approach the
problem but it basically has similar
sensitivity once it's a fully
operational will have similar
sensitivity this was begun by two
scientists in parallel with the efforts
that were described by Ray Elaine brulee
and Alberto Giotto and in the present
day run a little bit like us having a
laboratory where the director is farini
Frederico Farini and the spokesman who I
hope I think is here today is yo van der
brand from Holland and it's very near
Pisa in Italy it's not just this
confidence which of course matters that
somebody independent sees the same thing
that's great and at this point we don't
really need that we're pretty convinced
that we're seeing gravitational waves
but and we were in competition for
twenty years I think to see who could
see gravitational waves first but it
gives us new information and that's
shown here with just the first detectors
we were able to locate even on the first
event that it came from the southern
hemisphere and we knew to some number
six or seven hundred square degrees
where it came from and the various
events are shown here in how well we
could tell where they came from before
we turned on the Virgo detector
the veer goatish texture once it's on
because it gives us triangulation and
we're with the signal they see compared
to ours where we take the time
difference in the arrival time at the
different detectors and the difference
in the signal because the antenna
patterns are somewhat different gave us
this signal down here and you can see
that we now can locate with the addition
of ear go the location on the sky where
a gravitational event came very
accurately this is something we've
always wanted to do and luckily for us
this happened just in time and I'll show
you that in a minute first let me
reflect on what we found so far seeing
five events we've seen where this is
mass and this is just the time passing
the number of events these are each skim
bollocky ly two black holes coming
together making a heavier black hole
they're all up here on the plot where
this is mass what was expected was black
holes that would be down here so we
immediately something we've always
thought using gravitational waves would
see different phenomenon that are seen
in electromagnetic radiation and what we
saw was large black holes they're not
expected just qualitatively the reason
is the progenitor or the heavier object
that makes these black holes is supposed
to be a heavy star that decays and makes
a black that dies and collapses and
makes a heavy makes a black hole there
aren't we believe very heavy heavy
enough stars to make these very easily
there has to be either a special place
in the universe where it's low enough
metallicity or doesn't have heavy
elements around him so it can live
longer or dense clusters or primary
primordial production that made these
black holes and that's our next problem
like all these problems in physics is
where do these black holes come from
there are handles on it we hope to get
more information on the spins on the
orientations on the distributions and to
be able to resolve that the second thing
that has come out of the very first
events is test of general relativity
this is a graph where we just put in a
form that would be qualitatively are
different from general relativity just
to test it not a particularly one limit
of that is to look at the physical place
where you would have connected to the
transmission of gravitational waves what
we call a graviton very much like for
electromagnetic waves we have a photon
or for particle physics there's all the
particles we a graviton if it existed
does not exist in Einstein's theory
could have a mass and what we're able to
do is if it had a mass it changes the
detailed shape of that trace that we
looked at and we're able to say already
just a based on these very first
observations that if there is such a
mass it's less than 7 10 to the minus 23
electron volts over C squared so those
are tests the next was a rather
fortunate coincidence we got there go
into our into our system working
together two weeks before this happened
in later in August by the way we were
scheduled to turn off at the end of
August so this happened fortunately just
before we turned off well for the first
time we saw a second kind of event the
merger of a binary neutron star system
instead of a binary neutron star system
instead of a blackhole system what is a
neutron star again ray mentioned neutron
stars it comes from the collapse of a
star also we believe but it's a dense
it's dense nuclear matter instead of a
black hole if it's dense nuclear matter
if we have two objects going around each
other it has all kinds of nuclear
effects in addition to just the general
relativistic
merger and this is nuclear physics and
extreme conditions and we can then see
all kinds of effects including the fact
that the nuclear effects can give and
emit light in various ways we basically
could tell from what we saw that these
were much lighter like neutron stars are
supposed to be than the black hole
events they were a distance much closer
than that 50 mega parsecs instead of 20
times that that we saw for the black
holes and fortunately for us the signal
was also seen two seconds later in an
astronomical instrument that was the
Fermi satellite that monitors gamma-ray
bursts this is a picture of our signal
and put on their trace and where they
saw a signal over here is the same
pictures of the location on the sky our
location on the sky is these long
pictures here if it was just like oh but
when we add Virgo
it's this little ellipse here and this
is the position as determined by the
Fermi satellite one thing that makes me
feel great is that we're the ones that
actually have the better location even
though we're beginners at this game so
and that's very important for the future
so this picture is what we think is the
indication of what the future is going
to pretend this particular event then
having the confidence that it was seeing
both in an electromagnetic instrument
the Fermi telescope and us could be
studied for hours days and weeks after
that and has been looking at
gravitational waves of course looking
for it with neutrinos looking with a
visible and infrared light radio waves
gamma rays and x-rays and so forth using
this a whole set of collaborations and
conclusions have been made from this one
observation already which by the way we
announced only a little over a month ago
out two weeks after the Nobel
announcement we announced the merger of
two neutron stars so even after whatever
we got this price for we're still
producing very interesting new things
I'll just give you a glimpse I'm out of
time and a few of the different kinds of
phenomenon that are cut and
interpretation that came out of this
single first coincidence event with
electromagnetic instruments kind of to
whet your tongue and what's going to
happen in the future
the first is an independent pretty
independent measurement of what's called
the Hubble constant this is basically
the rate at which the universe is
expanding it's done by in this case
optically identifying what galaxy it was
in and then otherwise from the
information we have in the gravitational
wave signal and the answer this
so-called Hubble constant is independent
of and consistent with the answers that
came in electromagnetic interactions the
second which I won't go through an inny
detail is that there's been a lot of
phenomenology of what happens when
objects like these neutron stars come
together we all know what a supernova is
the collapse of a star when it gets old
and dies the this is tabbed a Killa Nova
the consequence of this coming together
and that's been studied now in all these
different instruments and put together
and compared with some of the
phenomenology that's been developed for
a killer nova and at least the general
idea confirmed one consequence which is
interesting is the possibility that we
have actually figured out our scene what
makes heavy elements in the sky in the
heavy elements of puzzle has always been
how on earth do we have very heavy
elements where did they come from you
can go on a mine and find gold ore
Platinum or other heavy elements where
do they come from we know most of the
universe is made out of hydrogen and
helium we know how to make everything up
to iron very easily it's made in the
same fusion process that makes the Sun
the Sun burns but making heavier
elements in nature we don't really know
we do know how to make them in the lab
we make them all the time and the
periodic table has gone up quite high we
basically take a heavy element and
bombard it with neutrons it sounds
familiar in neutron stars so the
neutrons are the way we do it in the
laboratory so the idea is very tempting
that may be in nature it's collisions
like we just observed that is neutron
star collisions that made heavy elements
this graph here is one phenomenological
interpretation of that and the yellow
parts which you'll notice are mostly
yellow for gold and platinum which you
might have on your hand are come from
merger of neutron stars at least in this
analysis and so maybe all the gold and
platinum that we sell on the earth we
finally discovered comes from collisions
like we've just announced a rather
interesting conclusion lastly I just
want to end with the future for a minute
or two we have now three detectors
working well soon have two more we have
one we're building in India a LIGO with
the collaboration of the Indian
physicists and Indian government that'll
be ready in the 2025 era there's one in
Japan that has some advanced techniques
which I'll mention which which should be
working within the next few years giving
us better localization this is an
incremental plot of how well we think
we'll be able to locate the position on
the sky as we move into the 2020s and
you can see that with the addition of
the other detectors independent of where
something comes from we should be able
to tell very well where it is and
combine then with electromagnetic
information we have ideas and also plans
for the future and I want to end on that
first as I showed you we're still about
a factor of
away from the design of advanced LIGO
that we will do over the next few years
again in a matter of steps and that
gives us almost a factor of 10 2 cubed
in the rate or the significance of
individual events we have concepts for
getting beyond that we we know that we
should at least think and do the Rd and
possibly ask to be funded for a concept
that would exploit our sites where we
have LIGO to there exfoli 610 and so
we've basically done conceptual designs
of that we can improve by making a much
heavier test mass by using a different
material in the mirrors we're presently
looking at silicon by lowering the
temperature modestly by improving a
limitation we have that is the coatings
the optical coatings on the mirrors that
Ray showed and by making yet a more
powerful laser if we do that we can get
down to the black curve that's shown in
this plot here and that will enable us
to have more cosmological reach which
which will be talked about by Kip some
of the ideas of what we might be able to
do improve signal the noise which will
what we've learned is that we need to
have events where we have such good
signal-to-noise that we can determine
things like the orientation of the spins
of the black holes and so forth and an
event rate that's maybe 10 times
advanced LIGO if we in it put in all
these this will require Rd and we
haven't yet the funding and haven't
firmly proposed to do it the next steps
are to you to do other reactions that we
can do on the Earth's surface but also
and this is some of those as possible
and Kip will talk about those but it's
already basically in this community
ideas that are fairly well developed for
how you would move to the next
generation detector
it's completely possible we don't see
any great technical hurdles in
extrapolating this up to a detector
that's a factor of 10 are so better than
present detectors what's the right
detector is what we have to work on and
to do that we have to set our priorities
in science we can't do everything
there's two main concepts right now on
the table one is to go underground make
the detector cryogenic so it's cooler
this very much helps the lower
frequencies we're going underground
there's a shaking of the earth cooling
the detectors you have less thermal
noise this is a concept that's been
developed in Europe and it's called the
Einstein telescope and they've been
working on it for about five to five or
so years and it's pretty firmly design
maybe not costed but at least the
concept is really designed in the US
we've been looking at another approach
which is to make basically a LIGO like
detector but much bigger that is to make
a detector this forty kilometers instead
of 4 kilometers you'll remember from
Ray's talk that lengths basically you
gain linearly so if we can make it 40
detectors and do everything else as well
we're ten times better basically and
this would be then on the Earth's
surface which is cheaper but we have to
worry about the fact that there's
Earth's curvature in that length it's
has arms that are 40 kilometers and
basically would have to have the
instrumentation that we use in initial
like oh the Viscardi is just starting
it's being led by Matt Evans who's
probably somewhere up here I can't see
him in developing a group that actually
will develop this concept over the next
few years we hope to develop both the
science priority so that we know what
has to be done what we want to do and to
begin to do the serious R&D that would
go into such detectors overall and this
is just a precursor of race of Kip's
talk the science as we move to the
future is going to be very much like
what has happened in astronomy
there's astronomy
started by Galileo looking through a
telescope at visible light we know now
we do astronomy by looking at visible
light x-rays infrared so forth and so on
the same thing is true here that we can
look at light we can look at
gravitational waves in a particular
frequency band on the Earth's surface
it's what's available to us where it's
quietest and that's the audio band if we
want to look at other frequencies we
have to use different methods the most
close to being done because it's
approved and funded is to do an
experiment and fit in space it's called
Lisa it'll move into the frequency band
of 10 to the minus 1 to 10 to the minus
4 Hertz instead of 10 to a thousand
10,000 Hertz like ourselves and that
covers a different frequency band and
what's shown above
and I'll leave that to Kip to talk about
is both some of the same phenomenon
looked at him at an earlier time in
their evolution and other phenomenon
that never reached the frequencies that
we get on the earth you can look at yet
lower frequencies one concept that's
being developed now that I don't have
time to talk about is to use a timing
from radio pulsars and that's being
looked at looking for signals at very
lower frequencies by monitoring the time
coming and we're looking for changes
from a set of radio pulsars and lastly
there are ways to get the effect of
gravitational waves from the early
universe which is the most interesting
of all in most of our minds when and if
it can be done and I'll leave it arrayed
to talk about those thank you
[Applause]
[Music]